the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today we're gonna talk about cooking
and stoves and charcoal and then there
will be plenty of time afterwards to
work on your project stuff ken is here
already a meet is around here and Amelia
will be coming it too so everyone has a
mentor to work with yeah so we did the
labs in Reverse so charcoal we did the
lab on Wednesday and even though it's
warmer today I think the rain would have
made it even less pleasant so I think
that was the right call
so we'll go through that a little bit
more yeah and I just explained
everything else so let's start just by
talking about cooking in developing
countries so what do people cook and
what are their needs for cooking soups
sweet potato and how do they typically
prepare that
there's a wide variety but so what are
the cooking things that you need to be
able to do for my energy perspective so
yeah anything else yeah
so that would be oven yeah
okay cool what else meat then what do
you do with me energy-wise I'm sorry
open fire anything else
so do anything else okay what else race
and that would be that captured here
yeah anything else
beans
it exists you don't see them a lot and
no okay so this is a modest list but
some things that are missing are bread
is a staple in a lot of places whether
it's a tortilla or Indian flatbread or
so most people don't boil meat so yeah
so so I'm not saying that this might be
a confusing way to present this I'm not
saying that every one of these requires
every one of these just that these are
some of the foods that you're cooking
and these are some of the ways that
you're preparing them so I'm just trying
to make sure that all of these are
captured or that all the methods are
captured but not linking yeah because I
I would be reluctant to eat boiled meat
straight without any other preparing
though I think like cabbage and corned
beef and cabbage is boiled so I think
you can do it
vegetables yeah
yep so meat is kind of uncommon on most
people staples so you get it
infrequently rice and beans or other
combos that make whole proteins are
pretty common and a lot of people live
on rice and beans pretty much every day
of their lives
with some tortillas sometimes and
nicaragua's certainly vegetables
oftentimes you grow some vegetables and
they they supplement but you live on a
staple of rice and beans a lot of what
we're working and in terms of the
cooking so for all of these they're sort
of the range of you need low heat or you
could need high heat you can need an
oven so these talking about sort of like
direct fire hitting the pan hitting the
food versus an oven is going to be more
convective and then yeah and people are
pretty picky about the control of their
fire for most of the or the heating
source for most of these options and so
you'll see the people who go to do both
Phoenix will definitely see this I don't
know about awesome Phoenix and ice or
prostar but a group of Phoenix a lot of
women there's a few women have gas
stoves but they still still maintain
their old style Adobe wood because they
will only cook their tortillas on wood
they they just can't they can't cook on
gas in a way that they believe makes it
acceptable tortilla so that is one of
the things that I want to emphasize
today I'm gonna keep coming back to it
is that people understandably are very
sensitive to how they cook and have very
long-standing traditions they are
cooking the same way their mom's cooked
and their moms and their moms and so
it's proposing to someone to cook in a
radically different way is challenging
and is something people are going to
resist for really understandable reasons
so we've got the low heat the high heat
in the oven that sort of captures it all
with boiling water you need high enough
heat that you can actually boil water
and each of those is critical the most
people that you can't cook with zero
with with only one ideally and so people
who even just cook on like three stone
fires with wood just get really good at
regulating the oven is sort of the
optional one that's the bonus but people
who cook with wood get really good at
regulating their fire so that they can
get their low heat or their high heat
depending on what they want because most
people need to be able to do both so
what fuels are typically used wood yep
I'm not asking radically crazy questions
I think there's another one that might
come out in your mind yes yep
yep
some people also cook with just general
biomass so that might be corn stalks or
hay or similar it's not a great fire but
if it's what you've got it's better than
nothing because one thing to note on
most of these is you can get away with
not cooking some of your vegetables
depending on how you fertilize them if
you did but you can't cook bread or you
can't skip cooking all of these and
expect to be able to digest them and so
cooking is a non-negotiable
it's you know our basic human need which
is part of why there's such a high level
of risk aversion because you're asking
people to change what they know is the
thing that's keeping them alive and
their family alive so some things to
just keep in mind generally about
cooking is that all modern fuel increase
with income except kerosene so people
tend to go from wood well from dung to
wood to charcoal to propane and kerosene
but then well it's as kerosene and then
to propane but people tend to stick to
propane for a while because it's it's
readily available and people get used to
it
in urban areas unsurprisingly biomass is
less common than in rural areas and in
those rural areas people often stick
with biomass forever because you know so
even if you can afford it it's still
easier to get wood that you can chop
down basically in your backyard than to
go get propane so you'll stick with it
and then another thing to think about is
that even if people have enough income
if you can't get your LPG or electric
stoves or whatever if you don't have
electricity you don't have the
infrastructure
you're not gonna switch and then we
often think about what I just said about
going into your quote backyard to gather
wood but a lot of people in relatively
rural areas purchase their wood rather
than collecting it either for time
reasons
because it's actually there's so much
deforestation that it's really hard to
get the wood both in terms of distance
and in terms of legality because often
it's cutting down wood on other people's
property and so you are avoiding doing
the directly illegal thing and just
purchasing it it's less common in
Central America or we'll be going but in
a lot of regions cutting down wood is
for fuel is now a crime and so but there
is no alternative cooking method and so
it still happens but now it's illegal
and so it's become more challenging in
that respect and more expensive in terms
of how people cook it really ranges in
places that have you know similar levels
of wealth you can see huge variations so
there's LPG electricity kerosene and
wood in Guatemala whereas here in Ghana
wood is really used very little and coal
charcoal really is used quite a bit more
so it varies place to place what people
use and a lot of that has to do with how
far away the wood is how and therefore
how expensive it is and a lot of other
factors but you just you should not
assume sort of this goes back to week
one like everyone cooks with wood in a
developing country you it's very
location specific and even location
within the country specific what people
are doing the challenges with fuel are
that it can be up to a third of people's
income just to pay for fuel and a third
of your income is kind of insane
if you imagine spending a third of your
income on fuel the poorest people in the
US are the ones who paying the most or
paying less than 1% of their income on
cooking fuel so if you manage imagine
going from something that costs you 1%
of your income to 30 30 % that's getting
really substantial and people who are
collecting it are sometimes in some
areas spending up to 7 hours a day
collecting firewood which is basically
the same impact in your family that if
you're spending 7 hours a day you're
not having any time to do anything else
but get enough food fuel for cooking
your food and then just looking at the
energy densities of all of these so wood
charcoal and the charcoal that we made
on Wednesday over it is very similar to
wood charcoal you can get really good
wood charcoal that's better than our
arse and you can get really junky wood
charcoal that's worse than ours so we're
about in the middle there everything
else that's a biomass because it's not
compressed and or processed is going to
be worse dung is quite poor both on
energy density as well as health because
you can imagine burning dung is worse
than burning anything else and then
heating oil all the things that were
used to generally gas or electric well
actually doesn't really fit in here but
gas is certainly a whole lot better and
so of course people are going to switch
to here if they can but it's expensive
and challenging and just from a visual
standpoint these are all the cooking
options to think about so there's
electricity propane wood these are
typically wood ovens dung this is the G
Co stove that I'll show a little bit
later which can be used with charcoal
there's cooking in and then there's a
variety of different cooking stoves that
you can cook with and then this is just
a three-stone fire so you can see
there's three stones here to support
your pot and then you feed your logs in
this way to cook your food so that's
just a quick overview on cooking we're
going to get into it more but I wanted
to switch gears and do a quickest
estimation and it says in teams of two
if you want to do it and three or four
that's fine too but what's the energy
required to boil a liter of water and
what's the efficiency to do so
go
you
yeah so I want to talk a little bit
about design considerations for stoves
and some of you may be working on those
projects so what do you think you have
to worry about when you design a stove
airflo yes
definitely what else
yeah
the environment you're in okay yep so so
safety
yeah
sighs yeah
heat source
anything else
yeah so if you're cooking outside
certainly I think I'm below the magic
line our night
anything else
yep
all the music
and angles already
so it is alright well this is a good
start to just give you a sense of the
list that I came up with another person
there's the insulation and the thermal
mass and this is actually a complicated
issue because in some cases like in with
an oven you want really really good
thermal mass so you heat up your that
thermal mass and then the thermal mass
allows you to cook longer whereas for a
charcoal stove you don't want a big
thermal mass you don't want necessarily
zero thermal mass but if you have too
much thermal mass the charcoal will use
all its energy in transferring it to the
stove and you won't be able to cook very
much with it
airflow is another important
consideration the reason the gqo works
so poorly on Wednesday was actually
because the door never got open that was
my fault
I'd realized that after when I was
cleaning up then we never opened the
door which meant there was no airflow
which pretty much limits the ability of
the fuel to get hot the volume so yeah
um which we mentioned how much you're
gonna cook is huge people have really
varying needs their robustness to water
so I'm going to the G Co one of the
challenges with it is it's made of
ceramic which makes it a really nice
insulator but as we talked about if you
pour water on to it to prevent the to
put out the charcoal the charcoal the
ceramic is going to crack and also if
you drop it the storm is going to crack
but boiling water it's pretty common for
some water to run over the edge of the
stove and so that alone can cause
cracking the cost of the device is
really critical
is this is such a fundamental need
everyone needs one and so if it's
unaffordable that's pretty problematic
longevity is another concern a lot of
these metal stoves that I'll be showing
in a second or not don't have a lot of
longevity but they do they are
affordable and so Paul Pollock would be
really happy with that
singing act other people would be less
happy but it is an issue the heating
options so ideally you could have some
magic stove where you could use any sort
of fuel right you could use charcoal or
wood or buy um regular biomass or
propane or electricity or whatever you
could get you'd have this magic stove
but that's not very realistic from the
price standpoint and but people do like
to be able to cook with a range of fuels
ease of use is definitely important if
it's hard to light or hard to keep the
fire lit or hard to get your pot on it's
pretty unfortunate stove emissions is
another thing to think about in terms of
where does the smoke go a lot of times
it goes straight into the kitchen you'll
see in the homes in Nicaragua the stoves
look a lot like this and even when they
do have a chimney it's rare that all
three holes for the pots are covered and
so the chimney in that situation it
doesn't work very well a lot of the
smoke escapes efficiency so how much of
the heat actually gets to cook as
opposed to doing something else style
aesthetics are all pretty important
people do want their kitchens to be
attractive and so while it's we're not
talking about a criteria similar to does
it look like the stainless steel kitchen
and a high-end kitchen or you know a
professional stove at a high-end kitchen
in the US it's still a really critical
thing to think about and a really junky
looking stove will not do very well and
then flexibility for fuels or different
types of foods etc etc so I'm just gonna
certainly can turn around to go to the
back corner and show you a wide variety
of stoves so this is one of the stoves
we used yesterday and it's a pretty
simple wood stove that's a relatively
common design so you can see that it has
the upper surface for cooking with I'm
not really sure what these decorative if
these are just decorative or if there's
some purpose to them but it did prevent
us from using a certain pot yesterday so
it's a frustrating element
yeah so it might be to hold a special to
the pot absolutely and then a place to
catch the ash it's pretty handy as well
so that people so that the ash doesn't
just fall on the ground
and it has plenty of holes for air to
allow for air flow the gqo this is a
these two are called chicos which is a
design of a stove that was developed in
Africa in Kenya I believe and the G Co
has a ceramic part that holds your fuel
and also acts as an insulator and then
metal everywhere else this one was not
made as carefully and maybe a knockoff
of this one which you can see the
ceramic liners actually thicker on this
one so it works a little better it has
the door that allows you to control air
flow so that's a big improvement over
this one on the installation it has
these three pieces which allow you to
hold a smaller pot it has little handles
that may or may not work too well this
is pretty heavy for such small handles
so I don't like actually carrying it
like that but it's a quite improved
stove and in terms of efficiency I
believe it cuts fuel use down by like
thirty percent so it's significant this
is an interesting stove can you see this
okay so this is a knockoff gqo and so
you can see that it kind of looks like
the G Co but it's got a bigger door it
has some really monstrous handles that
are actually easier to use than those so
that's a big improvement but it actually
has so much thermal mass in it that it
gets to that issue if there's so much
thermal mass that you use all your fuel
heating the stove rather than cooking
and so
it takes forever to cook with this like
a ridiculous amount of time and so it's
one of those like well if this emergent
installation is good this must be better
assumption that is really common we
actually with our charcoal we found that
if we make a charcoal that's people like
or I'll talk about it more but a bigger
chart piece of charcoal that they can
cut in half and make into the same
pieces of charcoal that our denti-cal in
size but they preferred the bigger size
and same with stoves people tend to
bigger is better is the assumption these
are these next four I'm going to show
our all stoves I bought in Nicaragua so
this one it's cool because it was a tire
hub so a nice user recycling these legs
allowed it to actually be at this height
which is pretty great however for
bringing it back on the airplane I cut
off the legs mostly charcoal in
Nicaragua is used just for frying up
food at places called for Tonga's and so
they're just done on street corners and
it's a sales thing it's rare to see
these in people's homes this is one can
anyone tell what this is made out of so
it's actually a gas cylinder that got
cut up probably when it died and then
rebar is the grading this one is really
really simple
and just used out of sheet metal it's
galvanized so if you use it inside its
gonna make people sick because the
galvanized metal gives off fumes that
are not so great and then this one is an
interesting design that's pretty common
usually made out of a it's usually
bigger it's like a 55-gallon drum but I
could bring that home on the airplane
and this one is interesting because it
allows you to use charcoal or wood
because you can feed the wood in this
way like you would in a traditional
Adobe stove and so it's nice that it
does have that flexibility compared to
all the others
oh and all of them generally come
painted and then the paint all chips
away as you cook with it but that does
sort of speak to the aesthetics interest
that people want to buy a nice looking
painted stove even if the paint doesn't
last very long it helps them sell yeah
yeah that really
so what though that time identified was
that it was important that this be made
by the women locally and so therefore
they decided that a single piece of
sheet metal was going to be easier for
the women to make locally than making it
out of many pieces you as a team if you
end up working on their project may come
to a different conclusion that's the
conclusion they came up with yeah so in
Nicaragua there's plenty of people who
well mostly with oxy-acetylene or stick
welding but in the rural villages there
aren't and so for example and we're a
group of Phoenix is there isn't a welder
in the village in the community but if
you went out to oak at all you can find
people who weld so there's definitely
welding capability you should consider
that local but it's not something that
like the women in the village could do
and so that's why they didn't come up
with a welded stove was because they
wanted to be something other women could
do themselves so some two really good
resources or cook stove net which goes
more into the theory of cook stoves and
Aprovecho
which is a huge organization that
there's a lot of stove design and
testing and they have a lot of great
resources about how to design stoves how
to test Toves etc are there any other
questions about stoves okay so I'm going
to talk some more about charcoal so two
and a half billion people cook with
biomass so that's sort of the market
we're talking about as opposed people
cooking with gas or electricity and it's
generally people living on less than two
or three dollars a day though there's
some wide range on that and there's
really no viable alternative I'll talk
about solar cookers a little later
propane fuel is just unavailable and
same with the grid in these regions
and so cooking with biomass which I got
into a little has some real problems so
there's a million 1/2 people who die
every year from indoor air pollution and
that's generally associated with cooking
inside the home
smoking inside the home there's other
things that also contribute but indoor
air pollution from cooking is a huge one
and it's mostly women and children who
are the ones tending the fires and
taking the biggest hit here so there was
a study done that estimated that if
everyone who currently cooks with wood
or dung and straw and biomass that's raw
switched to charcoal half of those lives
would be saved right off the bat with no
added ventilation no other changes just
switching from wood to charcoal because
it's that much cleaner but then you get
into the environmental issue of we're
talking about regions that can be facing
six to ten percent deforestation rates
and areas that are up to 98% deforested
and so if you encourage everyone to
switch to charcoal you're going to be
using up more wood and you're gonna
decimate the environment even further
and as I mentioned before there's also a
poverty aspect to cooking fuel in terms
of how much money and our time it takes
to be able to cook so the charcoal that
we talked about on Wednesday has some
benefits and that it burns as cleanly as
wood charcoal it's using a true waste
the complicated part about using a true
waste is that in every region some of
the possible wastes are not true wastes
and so corn cobs and stalks can be used
in farms too or any of these materials
can be used in farms to replenish the
soil basically except sugarcane which
really has no nutritive value once you
press the sugar out of it and so in
places where people are using that to
replenish the soil it's a really bad
idea to encourage them to switch to
making charcoal from it because they're
going to decimate their land and the
land is so valuable however in most
farms that are the subsistence level you
can find some biomass that's rotting and
so that's the biomass we target so
that's why we try to have a process that
works with a huge variety of waste so
that you can use a wide variety of waste
and only use the stuff that's waste the
nice thing about using the true waste is
that it tends to be rotting in such a
way that's producing a lot of methane
gas which is a very the worst one of the
worst greenhouse gases and worse for the
environment than burning the material
and so they're actually areas where you
get carbon credits just for burning
sugarcane waste rather than letting it
rot and so here rather than just in
helping the environment by burning it
we're using that fuel to cook with as
well as not getting the methane in the
environment so just to give you a sense
of where this project is so a few years
ago we got a $200,000 grant from the
World Bank to make charcoal and so we
trained more than a thousand people in
Haiti and the meth in the method and we
have some workshops or ateliers in Haiti
that are making the charcoal now
typically the costs associated with the
charcoal are just the drum and the press
and so the drum is anywhere from ten to
thirty dollars in a country and the
press generally is to to about two
dollars to make
if someone's asking telling you they're
gonna make it for ten they're ripping
you off some pushback because most
people do when you talk to welders most
people talk about how expensive it is
but if you push two dollars is a pretty
standard price we found almost
everywhere so the process that we went
through yesterday was we took the raw
waste wrote it into a drum let it on
fire covered it then it you're in an
anaerobic environment for about two
hours and then you have your charcoal
fines which you crushed and the bag in a
bag method and the rice husks mixed with
a binder made from yucca briquette it
and then you can put the briquettes back
in the drum to harden them after they've
dried and then you can cook with them so
I just want to make sure that you guys
are all comfortable with this method
because you'll be doing it most of you
will be doing it having only done it
once and so I just want to make sure you
are feeling confident so that's why I'm
we're viewing it in so much detail so
when you load the drum you need to
remember to have the stick in the middle
to make your chimney you can use the
fuses at the bottom to help light the
drum and it works really well to light
from the bottom rather than the top at
the top if you just light from the top
you'll get much less this effective
burning when you're covering up the drum
again you first you see this smoke and
actually we actually saw very little of
the just white smoke we saw most the
yellow smoke the just white smoke is
water and so if you're getting a ton of
just white smoke that means your waste
is too dry you're almost never gonna see
it as dry as we had on Wednesday because
that too wet excuse me yeah to die so
you almost never see it as dry as we had
on Wednesday because that has been
sitting in a heated incredibly dry
environment at MIT for about a year and
so that helps it dry out at a level that
you're never gonna see in the field
right and that's why it was infected
with cockroaches because of all those
because it was spending so long and the
bowels of MIT so you will see some white
smoke but if that's all you're getting
that's an indicator that your stuff is
too wet or if the drum just won't catch
on fire at all and then you get the
yellow smoke and then you get the flame
and then you wait some period of time
and I'm sorry I can't give you a seven
minutes answer for how long you wait
until you switch but things to look for
are remember how it would look like this
but then you'd get puffs of the yellow
smoke and so you want to wait and see
you're no longer getting those puffs of
yellow smoke because those are areas
that haven't gotten any heat yet that
are now starting to catch on fire and
then later on what queued me to cover it
up was we're starting to get black smoke
and the black smoke tends to mean that
we're we're burning everything really
fast and so that's what we needed to
cover it up but it is a judgment call
and it is tricky and so there's no easy
way
everything from humidity to the
temperature to the type of the the way
that what was in the drum before that's
another thing to think about is if when
you get an oil drum you don't know where
you're getting it from and so it may
have oil in it and so you may need to do
like a pre burn with just a little bit
of material to burn out whatever junk is
in the drum so that you have a clean
drum clean-ish drum to use for
carbonization because you didn't you
wouldn't want like oil and pregnant for
cats because that would burn pretty
nastily and you can do side by side
carbonization if you have a few drums
which is nice and then covering it up
just doing it relatively quickly but
also carefully so you don't get burned
because the drum is really hot at that
point for making the binder just
remembering that you're going for this
really it's not like consistency so
checking to make sure you get it before
you use it because if you don't the
briquettes will completely fall apart
and that's problematic and then using
the right amount so that you actually
get a good briquette is important and
then briquetting so I just wanted to
show you a couple of other briquette
press examples so the press presses we
used yesterday are really simple and
I'll talk about how we got there but
there's a cup an ejector pin and a
plunger and the block is just because we
don't have tables with holes in them
around here but it's pretty easy to find
some sort of hole you can use so you
don't actually need a block but you
should every team should plan to bring a
press with you so and then ideally you
can make them there but it's nice to
have one it's a show as an example to
your welder you can leave it there if
you need to and Haiti our colleagues got
tired of making one briquette at a time
so they came up with this press that
makes four at a time and then has a
plate that slides out sort of like our
old-style press that I'll show you in a
minute to make four briquettes at a time
the problem is you're just increasing
the area so you're distributing the
pressure and so you really have to wail
on this press to make briquettes well
and 2 mm 9 they made an
device to make briquettes which is nice
but a lot of material so yeah and just
when you briquette them make sure you're
hammering with enough force that you
actually get well compacted briquettes
or else they won't when they dry they'll
fall apart so I want to talk a little
bit about how the briquette press came
to be because I think a lot of d-lab you
sort of you work on a project and then
you're done you hand off the community
maybe and it seems like that's all that
it takes and at least in this case and I
think in a lot of cases there's more
required to get to a good product so
initially we made briquettes just by
hand as you can see in this picture and
you can imagine compressing that
material hard enough to get a really
solid briquette it was pretty painful on
the hands and it really didn't make very
good briquettes even if you were super
strong compressing the briquettes so
then we looked at buying a briquette
maker and the mechanised ones that we
could find were about eight thousand
dollars and it's entirely inappropriate
and so there was a bunch of work done by
Jessica vesical to figure out the best
method for actually making briquettes
and she honed in on impact forming them
and so she designed a briquette maker
here and so this is one of the earliest
prototypes that had a handle actually
that's the handle for the door let me
show you the next picture I think it's
easier to see so you load your material
in the top and then it falls to the
bottom the store is closed then you put
the plunger in close it with a pin hit
it a few times and then when you open
this that this plate at the bottom has a
pin sticking out the back and so it hits
the back pin and that pushes the
briquette out so you can grab it so it's
a really nice design and it made fortify
briquettes a minute so we were pretty
happy with it but it was kind of slow
and frustrating and so first the first
improvement was to do a time study to
figure out what was taking so long and
how to improve it and everything was
taking a long time but ejecting was
taking like the most time loading was
taking a while
and so we someone that Amy Smith worked
with
came up with an improvement which got us
to six to eight briquettes per minute
and so you can see that some of the
improvements were instead of loading
from the very top which required a lot
more precision you loaded from the side
and for ejecting instead of having a
special ejection mechanism which
required a lot of cleaning you just
pulled this plate out and then drop the
briquette down and then we actually will
actually I can show you the presses
there over here so this one that you can
see down here it has this plate and so
the briquette drops down there like that
plunger is trying to and then when you
close this drawer it actually pushes the
briquette out of the way so it's a
little bit mechanized and so it helps
the it helps speed things up
considerably and so we were really happy
with it but it was also a relatively
expensive design because this plate had
to be quite thick and this is a really
expensive piece of metal just right here
and so we were pretty concerned about
the prices of some of these elements and
so we had another person who does a lot
of work in Guatemala take a look at it
and redesign it unfortunately I wasn't
able to find one of these presses in
d-lab today but he just made some subtle
improvements so that that big plate was
cut down until it was just as wide as
the diameter of this shaft and then
everything else was made with an angle
iron an angle iron is relatively cheap
and available everywhere and so that
made it a whole lot more affordable for
our partners another yeah there a
variety of changes and so you can see
just just looking at it there there's a
bit loose metal here is the biggest
change and that improved things a lot
there is it that was not I would say
that very significant compared to
actually this method I think that the
meant that we have now is there's more
waste that we just do it on the tarp so
that we collect that waste so we still
weren't happy with the price and so we
ended up radically redesigning it by
removing all the material basically to
just the most basic elements and so and
we started with a circular design and
that still stands but we've also added a
square design so that if you have a
cylindrical stock you can use it and if
you don't if you have a square stock you
can use it one of the nice things about
square stock is that it's a little bit
more flexible in terms of these parts
the two parts that you need to fit into
the into the press you don't need to cut
a careful circle you can just cut a
square and that's a lot easier and then
same on the bottom you can just weld
these pieces on so we took that to the
field and we got a few different designs
back as improvements so this one is just
just used sheet metal that's bent around
and then welded on the edges and so that
further reduced cost because it's
thinner it's a thick sheet but not as
thick and then this group used angle
iron you can see and put four pieces of
angle to iron together and weld of the
edges which is requires a talented
welder but if you have one does is a
really nice way to do things and so
there's a whole variety of little
improvements that are still being made
but generally we're very happy with this
press now it's interesting a note that
some of our partners still prefer this
press as I mentioned because of the
whole bigger-is-better issue that they
just really like this because they feel
like it's sturdier even though it's ten
times the cost and has no additional
value in terms of speed or labor comfort
or anything like that so that's been one
of our challenges as to people who saw
this press first they still want to use
it because they prefer it
despite the cost difference and so
that's one thing we're trying to work
out is how do we get that cachet into
this press that is so much more
affordable so all that des said and this
is a lot of years of effort of improving
and approving in small and big ways and
so it's just worth thinking about all
the different ways that a product needs
to be improved past the you know initial
prototype which is the stage that you'll
be getting to so I wanted to make a
couple other comments about running a
training because you guys will be doing
at least two group two of the three
groups will be doing the charcoal
trainings in the field so just to start
out with you guys have any questions
about how you'll be running that
training have you thought about it at
all yet how are you feeling about doing
that yeah yeah so your mentor your trip
neither has the contact for your
community partner and so you guys should
be in contact with them to find out what
is there and what needs to be brought
and you should also be reminding them
right now that they need raw material
the the waste they should be gathering
that and drying it right now any other
thoughts or comments
so just the one thing to think about is
what's the balance between you doing a
demonstration and you having the people
there actually getting involved in
getting their hands dirty and doing the
work and how do you balance that both
from a pedagogical standpoint how do you
help them learn this activity the best
and then also so making sure you have
the dry waste that's truly dry is huge
loading the drum not getting cut because
people often get cut in that step making
sure you really think before you light
the drum on fire is critical as well as
making sure things are kind of calm
during the fire because often times
things get a little hectic it's exciting
when there's fire and people things can
get out of control and we've had issues
where like a drum got knocked over onto
its side when we were covering it up
because people were just too crazy and
so you know it's it's not insanely
dangerous but it is dangerous and so
it's worth just making sure you have
that under control crushing is pretty
easy when you have a big group because
everyone takes a turn jumping on the bag
and that's really nice
making sure you're gonna keep the water
with the if you're going to heat the
wider with the charcoal with the with
the burn make sure you have that
prepared yeah those are the big ones and
then making sure everyone gets a chance
to use the pre-cut press because some
people get really into it and don't want
to give up the turn so make sure you do
that
all right so the rest of the class is
just time for you guys to work I want to
remind you to hand in these four
documents so that you can travel and
then just don't forget to do your muddy
cards are there any questions before you
guys get into groups okay cool